your responsibility as a leader is to
always keep your head up and give people
optimism and hope because you have done
the hard work to get them through the
tough times but then there's a point
where it is the fight ORF flight and
that's when you see the real courage
come out things go bad things go bad in
combat things go bad in universities
things go bad if you allow those
failures to crush you then you're not
going to make the next hard decision SK
training was a great equalizer nothing
mattered but your will to succeed and
you always need to be in a position to
make the next hard decision but take
into account the failures you've had